your German how many World Wars under
your belt now oh yeah all of them so fun
if you watch some of my videos did you
see the Second Amendment video that I
did on the on it not being just for
muskets oh yeah I loved all those cool
old guns yeah the the Belton flintlock
and the gerund Dhoni and the Puckle gun
yeah they're pretty cute names of them
were cool you know it's like oh this is
sweet yeah they were some pretty cool
names well I got some obviously some
hate mail from that and there's one here
that I would really like to read because
I find this pretty interesting so this
comes actually a comment on YouTube from
TOEFL Schneck Barr 667 that's somebody's
name it's their screen name he wrote I
agree to 95% but I think even that
argument comes to an end I don't think
that the American Founding Fathers had
nuclear warheads ballistic missiles and
poison gas and mind firstly show me how
you would use that for personal defense
you can't those are things created
solely for mass catastrophe that crap
belongs in the hands of trained
professionals are better and no hands at
all there should also be some kind of
regulation on who gets a gun and who
doesn't get one I don't think that
mentally ill people and criminals shut
have weapons just look at Germany my
home country you can own a gun but you
have to prove that you actually need one
for example you want a gun for hunting
good then you have to have a hunting
license and permit you need a gun for
sporting then you have to provide a
membership card and you have to go to
tournaments misspelled tournaments on a
regular basis that's an easy way to
filter out people who shouldn't have a
gun okay
tell a [ __ ] far Kershner bar 667 you're
German how many World Wars under your
belt now oh yeah all of them later
Howsam
you won't find it in our history books
how do you think the Jews would have
felt about that you think they might
have been better armed the exact reason
for the Second Amendment TOEFL shock Bar
667 is because of situations like
Germany your country and by the way
several times in your country's history
your country is the textbook we look at
Cochise we check we don't want that in
our country we better make sure our
citizens are armed so they don't huddle
them up and put them into gas chambers
and turn them into soap the fact that
someone who's German is telling me in
America that you guys are on this is
this is why we've done it correctly in
Germany this is why the government gets
to tell people who can and who cannot
have guns by the way Hitler disarmed
people that that's the first act of
nearly all dictators right that's as a
matter of fact Gandhi said of all the I
think the exact quote will bring it up
on screen of all the evil acts on behalf
of the English Empire robbing an entire
nation of arms will be known as their
blackest something like that anyway your
your German case closed
subscribe by clicking my face or click
this video next to me it's playing right
now in a box how do we do that that's
the magic of the Internet is it still
playing still playing I don't want to
look at it still playing isn't it